This lecture is a continued discussion
of generative probabilistic models for
text clustering.
In this lecture we're going to finish
the discussion of generative
probabilistic models for text
clustering.
So this is a slide that you have seen
before and here we show how we define
the mixture model for text clustering
an what the likelihood function looks
like and
we can also compute the maximum liklihood
estimate to estimate the
parameters. In this lecture, we're going
to talk more about how exactly we're
going to compute the maximum likelihood
estimator.
Now, as in most cases, the EM algorithm
can be used to solve this problem for
mixture models.
So here's the detail of this EM
algorithm for document clustering.
Now, if you have understood how EML
works for topic models, PLSA and I
think here it will be very similar and
you just need to adapt a little bit to
this new mixture model.
So as you may recall, EM algorithm
starts with initialization of all the
parameters.
So this is the same as what happened
before for topic models.
And then we're going to repeat until
their likelihood converges.
An in each step will do E step and M step.
in M step.
we're going to infer which distribution
has been used to generate each
document.
And so we have to introduce a hidden
variable ZD for each document and this
value variable could take a value from
the range of one through K representing
K different distributions.
And more specifically, basically we're
going to apply Bayes rule to infer, or
which distribution is more likely to
have generated this document or
computing the posterior probability of
the distribution.
Given the document.
An we know it's proportional to the
probability of selecting this
distribution P of Theta I and the
probability of generating this whole
document from that distribution, which
is a product of all the probabilities
of words for this document, as you see
here.
Now, as in all cases, it's useful to
kind of remember the normalizer or the
OR the constraint on this probability.
So in this case we know the constraint
on this probability in the E step is
that all the probabilities of Z equals
I must sum to one 'cause the document
must have been generated from precise
or one of these K topics.
So the probability of the generator
from each of them should sum to one.
And if this constraint then you can
easy to compute this distribution as
long as.
what it is proportional to, right?
So once you compute this product that
you see here, then you simply normalize
this these probabilities to make them
some to 1 what over all the topics.
So that's E step after E Step we would know
which distribution is more likely to
have generated this document D, which
is unlikely.
And then in the M step, we're going to
relist, made all the parameters based
on the, infer the Z values, or in
further knowledge about which district
has been used to generate which
document.
So there estimation involves two kinds
of parameters.
One is P of Theta and this is the
probability of selecting a particular
distribution.
Before we observe anything, we don't
have any knowledge about which cluster
is more likely, but after we have
observed these documents, then we can
collect the evidence.
To infer which cluster is more likely,
and so this is proportional to the sum
of the probability of Z sub DJ is equal
to I.
And so this gives us all the evidence
about using topic.
I said I to generate a document and we
put them together and again we
normalize them into probabilities.
And then so this is for P of Theta sub I.
Now the other kind of parameters are
the probabilities of words in each
distribution, each cluster, and this is
very similar to the case of PLSA.
And here we just pulled the counts of
words that are in documents that are
inverted to have been generated from a
particular topic Theta I here
and this would allow us to
then estimate how many words have
actually been generated from Theta I.
And then we normalize again.
These counts into probabilities so that
the probabilities on all the words
some to one.
Note that it's very important to
understand these constraints as they
are precisely the normalizers in all
these formulas, and it's also important
to know that distribution is over what?
For example, the probability of Theta
is overall the key topics and that's
why these K probabilities sum to 1.
well, whereas the probability of a word
given Theta is a probability
distribution over all the words.
So there are many probabilities and
they have to send one.
So now let's take a look like this.
Take a look at the simple example of
two clusters.
I have two clusters.
I've shown some initializer values for
the two distributions.
And let's assume we randomly
initialized to probabilities of
selecting each cluster as .5.
So equally likely.
And then let's consider one document
that you have seen here.
There are two words, sorry, two
occurrences of text and two occurrences
of mining.
So there are four words together.
Medical and health did not occur in
this document, so this first thing
about the hidden variables.
Now for each document we must use a
hidden variable and before in PLSA we
used 1 hidden variable for each word.
Because that's the output from what
mixture model.
So in our case the output from a
mixture model or the observation from
mixture model is a document not a
word.
So now we have 1 hidden variable
attached to the document.
That hidden variable must tell us which
distribution has been used to generate
the document, so it's going to take two
values, one and two to indicate the two
topics.
So now how do we infer which
distribution has been used to generate
the D?
It's to use Bayes rule so it looks like
this in order for the first topic is
setup, want to generate the document.
Two things must happen.
First theater subway must have been
selected, so it's given by P of 01
second.
It must have also been generating the
four words in the document, namely two
occurrences of text and two occurrences
of mining.
That's why you see the numerator has
the product of the probability of
selecting Theta one and the
probability of generating the document
from Theta 1.
So the denominator is just the sum of
two possibilities of generating this
document, and you can plug in the
numerical values to verify.
Indeed in this case the document is
more likely to be generated from Theta 1,  much
more likely than from than Theta 2.
So once we have this problem that we
can easily compute the probability of Z
= 2 given this document, how we're
going to use the constraint?
Right now it's going to be 1 - 100 /101
1,000,000 one.
So now it's important to note that in
such a computation there is a potential
problem of underflow, and that is
because if you look at the numerator,
the original numerator and denominator
it involves the computation of a
product of many small probabilities.
Imagine if a document has many words
and it's going to be a very small value
here, as it can cause the problem of
underflow.
So to solve the problem.
We can use a normalized.
So here you see that we take average of
all these two solutions to compute
another average district called Theater
Bar.
And this does the average distribution
will be comperable to each of these
distributions.
In terms of the quantities, the
magnitude.
So we can then divide the numerator and
the denominator both by this
normalizer.
So basically this normalizes the
probability of generating this document
by using this average word
distribution.
So you can see the normalizer here.
And since we have used exact the same
normalizer for the numerator and
denominator, the whole value of this
expression is not changed.
But by doing this normalization you can
see we can make the numerators and
denominators more manageable in that
the overall value is not going to be
very small for each, and thus we can
avoid underflow problem.
In some other times we sometimes also
use logarithm of the product to convert
this into a sum of log of
probabilities.
This can help preserve precision as
well, but in this case we cannot use
logarithms to solve the problem because
there's sum in the denominator, But
this kind of normalizes can be
effective for solving this problem, so
it's a technique that's sometimes
useful in other situations as well.
Now let's look at the M step.
So from the E step we can see our
estimate of which distribution is more
likely to have generated a document,
and you can see D1 is more likely
from the first topic.
Where is D2 is more like from the
second topic, etc.
Now let's think about what we need to
compute in the M step.
Basically we need to re estimate all
the parameters.
Let's first look at the P of Theta 1
and P of Theta 2.
How do we estimate that?
Intuitively, you can just pull together
the Z probability Z probabilities from
E Steps, right?
So if all these documents say they're
more likely from silouan, then we
intuitively would give a high
probability to see that one right?
So in this case, so we can just take
the average of these probabilities that
you see here, and we obtain the .6 for Theta 1
so Theta 1 is more likely
than Theta 2.
So you can see the probability of Theta 2
would be naturally .4.
What about these world probabilities?
What we do the same?
And intuition is the same, so we're
going to see in order to estimate the
probabilities of words in Theta one,
we're going to look at which documents
have been generated from Scylla and
we're going to pull together the words
in those documents and normalize them.
So this is basically what I just said.
Most specifically, we're going to for
example.
Use all the counts of text in these
documents to estimate the probability
of tax given still awhile, but we're
not to use their raw counts or total
account.
Instead, we can do that.
Discount them by the probabilities that
each document is likely be generated
from Theta 1.
So this gives us some fractional
counts, and then these Council would be
then normalized in order to get the
probability.
Now how do we normalize them?
These probabilities of these words must
sum to one.
So to summarize, our discussion of
generating models for clustering.
We showed that a slight variation of
Top Model can be used for clustering
documents and this also shows the power
of generating models in general by
changing the generation assumption and
changing the model slightly we can
achieve different goals and we can
capture different patterns in text
data.
So in this case, each class is
represented by unigram language model
or word distribution, and that's similar to
topic model.
So here you can see the word
distribution actually generates a term
cluster as a byproduct.
A document that is generated by first
choosing a unigram language model and
then generating all the words in the
document that using this single
language model and this is very
different from again topic model
where we can generate the words in the
document by using multiple unigram
language models.
And then the estimated model pamateter
will give both a topic capitalization
of each cluster and the probabilistic
assignment of each document into a
cluster.
And this probabilistic assignment that
sometimes is useful for some
applications.
But if we want to achieve a harder
clusters mainly to partition
documents into disjoint clusters.
Then we can just force the document
into the cluster corresponding to the
water distribution.
That's most likely to have generated
the document.
We've also shown that the EM algorithm
can be used with computer.
The maximum lag or is made up an.
In this case we need to use a special
normalization technique to avoid
underflow.